you know is howling you know howling at
our Reebok oops
a poodle the [ __ ] my wife my wife is
like literally you guys are the biggest
idiots on the planet but cracking I'm
guy Kim eyelashes like you as you do it
you need you should have to stand I'm
like that's a to I I look do it a fart
jokes let's cherry barbeque whoops whoo
there's something about values oh how
ridiculous is it sometimes you gotta
just fart in public for no reason
watts and Tim sorry the worst when
someone does not an elevator and then
they get off and you obviously you
shouldn't like shut out our plane buddy
get off and then they come on on a plane
come with a schedule a near come on are
you kidding me yeah I'm talking me it's
not good yes I'm good I'm are thoughts
of you when you don't over me no
remember we London own air biscuit
itself either luck can drop bring a cow
to its knees bring a cow in a power at
the end of manure lady tells have not a
feedlot with manure everywhere that cat
would still go loser and fall to a taste
okay and I go bro
and you go I go everybody can smell it
you just sitting there going tonight I'm
care and I was like you have to start it
remember that well I well I would like
to I mean you know my daughter hearing
my backhand early probably from the
smartest okay I'm ready eating that
cheese plate and wholeness and fard into
it bro it wasn't me I went I feel sick
Bryant you know I get sick on planes why
would you do it
was it me and I was laying it on me was
and I didn't do it you did I guarantee
your old Erin some controlled for that
that far though that onslaught of farts
in that air gave me accelerated my
[ __ ] backhand skin cancer because
you're recycled here it's not good
increase out inning which is which is
interesting because you're what I was
reading this Craig Mathare you're one of
six or seven children is that right
yes I got a lot of brothers and sisters
yeah and they're any of them fighters no
because I feel like it depends where you
at in that order
whenever you're one of seven one of six
one of eight my dad was one of 13 your
your vying for attention from the
parents from the family so a lot of
times again it depends we at in that
spectrum of a yum I'm all my older
brothers
I have one younger brother but all my
brothers and sisters are way older than
me
whatever yeah yeah so like I was I was
always getting attention no yeah I like
it because I'm good man screws in the
day attention yeah you should have to
vie for you know so as long as your
house your family feel about you
fighting doing all that my mom loves it
she loves it a little too much you know
I got teller like hell shell out my
mom's crazy to like to a point where she
just you know you have that was just
either you either have it or you don't
that mom is just like you have to keep
eyes on I'm gonna be like she's like at
the fights man she's just like I got a
watch like who tries to talk to her you
know as far as like any meteor talk
about my a yeah she's not she's not
nothing to admit like were you gonna ask
her I need noted by Buford all yeah
exactly I remember one time to in
Strikeforce they're always getting like
Woodley's mom on camera and she's like
the super churchgoer you know and I'm
just like and now he's used to looking
at sites like hell no the hell do I wear
when I be a mama you know I'm seeing
patios mom on pay-per-view yeah
so that's tough exam we know as the
crazy voodoo lady but he's doing this
weird thing she has a doll but pins in
it out everywhere I put together when
he's fighting for my leather every
single time he fights I guarantee you
they will find her every time yeah I
drama some part a lot of times she's
more entertaining exactly man people
create their own stagnant pond what
they'll do is they'll form their own
community where they don't have to
really hold each other accountable right
all the same right yeah right yeah so
that's why I was just talking about you
Stevie yesterday because he said you did
such a good job you know he said you
know you held their attention for two
hours you know and I was I got super
jealous and I insulted you but the thing
is this no but but I I'm but I never had
any doubt that you would do well because
you know Brendon is doing stand-up now I
know but he's not just doing stand-up
he's created his own touring business
he's selling out on the row he's going
to Australia with the big brown
breakdown I think it's [ __ ] I think
it's really special and I'm and I'm
still outraged by it right I don't
support it but here's the thing I just
hear the thing and also he's changed
he has his fame had not it's not as
respectful he's not he doesn't have any
advice anymore right you know what
[ __ ] let him fly bro you will be
unhappy not gonna cool I know but I'm
happy for you don't see please please
fly away on your own I should have met
ya the nest under leaves in there I drew
wings do you think they're big enough to
fight a [ __ ] Australian
good luck over those I think you know
his lines it flies first class my first
class this [ __ ] all [ __ ] blah
you're selling out on the road but the
point is that I was saying to my wife in
the John I said well when Brendan told
me that could have took him a while to
admit to himself what he really wanted I
was like III had been saying they want
to go I have no doubt this [ __ ]
going to succeed and you know by the
time he's 40 you're going to be seeing
you know in my opinion probably a really
good headlining comic with specials
under his belt which I know as part of
his dream there's no doubt and the
reason is because he never stops [ __ ]
moving and I know also that when he gets
in that stagnant pond what she did with
fighting and now with standing when you
see that you know what fuels them what
few of them is gone hey these people are
moving I'm just going to work harder now
and I think that's very important and
that's a true line with a lot of
successful people is it you just keep
taking action what are you right I mean
just keep moving forward you know there
what's interesting is you know one of
the quotes for the podcast we have is
you know life presents a brick wall and
some people either just stop and look up
and say wow that's a big wall and other
people like you know what I don't know
how long this wall is but I'm gonna get
around it but I'm gonna go under it I'm
gonna go over it I'm gonna put my hand
in my friend lit and I'm just gonna go
do it right I mean no lying telling that
he's not that funny early now he is a
Glee right I'm going to the store I have
a set tonight nothing [ __ ] forever on
a Tuesday